something that we did a couple of years
ago to try to improve the traction on
these R4 tires was grooving them all
right so I bought a grooving tool off of
Amazon I think it was around 100 bucks
give or take
and you heat it up and you basically
it's got a little metal knife and you're
just pushing through and cutting out
little grooves it gives all these extra
edges on here to get extra traction and
slippery surfaces and mud just off-road
applications and so the downside of
these R4 tires is they just
they're not great on Traction in a lot
of areas and basically it can be an
expensive Endeavor to completely replace
all of your tires with a different tread
pattern so for around 100 bucks give or
take whatever that tool is you can
enhance your traction on the existing
tires that you have and for me in the
last
year and a half or two years whatever
it's been I have definitely noticed an
improvement
a lot of other folks have been doing
this too so maybe ask around in the
forums and see what they think as well
so if you want to find the tool we use
we do have a link to it in our Amazon
store you can find that through our
website